der iran will dass die usa irak
verlassen hat donald trump tatsächlich
dem iran damit einen grossen gefallen
getan
kurzfristig ist das sicher so die iraner
wollen nicht nur dass es zumindest
erklärte politik der iranischen
regierung und des iranischen regimes die
wollen nicht nur dass die amerikaner
sich aus dem irak zurückziehen sondern
sie wollen insgesamt dass die amerikaner
sie aus der region zu holen sind also
man sich wenn man sich mit iranischen
diplomaten
klingt einfach unterhält
regierungsvertretern dann ist es eben so
dass sie sagen unser strategisches
interesse ist dass wir mit den staaten
in der region ein system aufbauen sollen
um uns mit denen wir zu arrangieren aber
wir möchten eben die dominanz der
amerikaner hier nicht mehr haben und
andere staaten regionen mit denen wir in
feindschaft oder in konkurrenz leben
wollen die amerikaner um jeden preis in
der region halten
und natürlich wollen die iraner die
amerikaner aus der region heraus haben
aber es ist eben ja in den letzten
jahren auch wir nun wieder auch nützlich
gewesen die amerikanische presse daran
und noch mal die frage auf die
amerikanische sicht mtv sind werden die
amerikaner denn gegen den willen der
jetzigen irakischen regierung im land
bleiben ich glaube sie müssen eigentlich
im land bleiben weil zu viele
strategische interessen dranhänge stehen
50.000 amerikanische soldaten in der
gesamten region davon 5000 auf
irakischem boden und das was sie da
einen erkenntnissen gewinnen auch über
den usa oder andere gruppierungen ist
wieder sehr wichtig für die sicherheit
der anderen für die stabilität der
region
es läuft momentan super für die
iranische regierung in tera die gabriel
hat vorhin gesagt sie können sich freuen
dass sie selber in politisch gestärkt
ist und keiner mehr groß über die
niedergeschlagene unruhen redet sie kann
sich freuen dass ihr einfluss ausgedehnt
ist und nun im iran im libanon
sie kann sich sehr freuen dass ich sage
es ganz klar auch eine bundesregierung
sich am samstag nach moskau auch auf
macht so hält putin ausgerechnet einem
engen verbündeten von syrien und dem
iran
und sie kann sich auch freuen das heiße
rief wohl von der eu empfangen wird und
möglicherweise eine schöne foto objekt
entsteht also momentan läuft alles
hervorragend und das erklärt vielleicht
auch warum auch die praxis wie die ist
dollar beispielsweise sehr zurückhaltend
sind bei diesen im grunde um sie sind
auf der siegerstraße das hat churchill
mal früher gesagt hat gesagt wer sich in
einen krieg einlässt in der überzeugung
dass er den auf jeden fall gewinnen
sollte auch mit bedenken dass ein
anderer nur in diesen krieg auch rein
geht wenn er auch der überzeugung ist
dass er gewinnt mit anderen worten
selbst wenn die usa militärisch so was
von überlegen sind
der politische sieg möglicherweise bei
den ihre anliegen und genau das
befürchtet frau becker dass wir in einer
solchen situation sind wo der iran
erstarkt nein ehrlich es war richtig
dass ich würde gerne zwei sachen dazu
sagen also zunächst zu der darstellung
dass nach dem atom abkommen alles besser
war
das haben sie ihr beide vertreten und
ich sehe das ganz anders also das ist im
juli 2015
das kann man eigentlich ganz gut zeigen
an diesem monat im juli 2015 sind sie ja
als erster minister in den iran gereist
mit einer großen handelsdelegation und
im westen war die erwartungen jetzt gibt
es wandel durch handel
wir haben gesehen dass es nicht der fall
gewesen ist und im gleichen monat ist
dann kassel sulimani oder kurz danach zu
putin gefahren und sie haben besprochen
wie sie den syrien krieg zusammen
intensivieren das heißt auch wenn es in
dieser zeit vielleicht paar weniger
anstieg gegeben hat liegt das
wahrscheinlich einfach darin dass das
iranische regime in diesem moment eben
auch syrien konzentriert war
und das ist finde ich kann man wirklich
nicht als gute situation bezeichnet sich
auch erklären
dadurch dass die amerikaner ein vakuum
gelassen haben gerade auch in syrien
durch das arug obama in syrien nicht die
rote linie versucht hat durchzusetzen
und donald trump das zunächst ja auch
nicht gleich findet nein es ist doch es
ging doch darum zu verhindern dass
dieses land sich in kurzer zeit in den
besitz von nuklearwaffen bringt und das
ist gelungen
kein mensch hat erwartet dass mit dem
abkommen die probleme mit dem iran
erledigt sind
es sollte die grundlage schaffen eine
weitere sozusagen schlimme entwicklung
zu verhindern jetzt wo wir jetzt sind ja
das haben jetzt alle beiträge irgendwie
gesagt ist dass diese entwicklung
gestoppt ist und übrigens niemand ich
ahne ich würde sagen der iran und un usa
es auf der gleichen stufe und natürlich
nicht es ist nur so dass die vereinigten
staaten von amerika unter donald trump
auf die frage wie denken eigentlich
verbündete über strategische entwicklung
keine rücksicht nimmt
das macht es für uns sehr schwer mit den
usa gemeinsame strategien zu entwickeln
eine der strategien die wir hatten war
parallel zu dem nuklear abkommen einen
zweiten verhandlungstag aufzumachen bei
dem wir reden über menschenrechte
ballistische raketen fragen jetzt die
das verhalten in der region die iraner
waren wir haben sogar gesagt wir machen
damit ohne dass wir gedacht haben dass
wir sozusagen in den nächsten jahren
dabei erfolg haben werden das war so
lange möglich solange wir sozusagen eine
grundlage hatten und das war das atom
abkommen jetzt sind wir in einer
situation wo ich glaube dass sie recht
haben dass in wahrheit die dinge in die
gleiche richtung gehen obwohl
verschiedene strategien damit betrieben
werden das ende und dafür hätte ich als
israeli als saudi ziemliche angst wir
als europäer sollten dafür auch angst
haben kann es sein dass der einfluss des
iran steigt und die vereinigten staaten
die region sukzessive verlassen nicht
morgen
aber das ist das strategische ziel nicht
erst unter tram und es sollte das finde
ich war das strategische klugheit von
obama zu sagen wer nicht daraus gehe
muss ich irgendwas reinpacken was das
vakuum gefüllt das ist weg das vakuum
wird jetzt besetzt durch terrorgruppen
ich vermute mal dass in moskau sich auch
gedanken über die frage gemacht wird wie
man das vakuum füllen kann
und das ist unser problem ich glaube es
wäre uns eine stunde für europa wir
müssten jetzt vielleicht meine ich habe
nichts dagegen dass frau merkel sich mit
putin trifft ganz im gegenteil gibt
genug zu bereden in der ukraine aber
jetzt finde ich müsste europa das
gleiche tun was wir schon mal gemacht
haben
2003 wollten die amerikaner mit
sozusagen dem hort des teufels in
teheran auch nichts zu tun haben da sind
ein deutscher und ein französischer und
britischer außenminister los und haben
begonnen mit den iranern zu verhandeln
dann haben sie es auf die ebene der un
gebrachten das ergebnis war dass ihr das
abkommen mit dem iran ich finde das sind
punkt wo europa ja jetzt was machen muss
jetzt setzt er jetzt okay jetzt und und
übrigens meine vermutung ist die
amerikaner werden dass gleich schlecht
finden
gestern man muss ja immer genau hinhören
gestern hat donald trump ja vieles
gesagt aber unter anderem auch die türen
für verhandlungen sein da er weiß auch
dass nicht sozusagen der ayatollah zum
telefon greifen und sagt okay lass uns
reden sondern das jetzt ganz andere
agieren müssen das ist jetzt pech
channels geben muss da ist jetzt der
europäer kommen müssen es gibt kanäle
über die schweiz
es gibt welche über manche golfstaaten
das ist jetzt finde ich eine stunde wenn
die lage so schlecht ist jetzt muss
europa seine diplomatischen kanäle
nutzen seine ökonomischen möglichkeiten
und ich bin ziemlich sicher dass wie
die amerikaner nicht beifall klatschen
werden öffentlich aber sie haben hätten
schulden
sie werden sagen lass dir das machen
denn ihr strategisches ziel ist die
region zu verlassen
und wir müssen vorher dort eine andere
lage haben sonst sind wir blank und
überlassen das den gewalttätern wie
vielleicht gucken wir uns auch die
historie dieses noch mal an unser
verständnis unterschiedlicher hätten die
interpretationen des atomdeals nicht
sein können schlechtestes abkommen aller
zeiten kronjuwel der diplomatie die
meinungen gingen da sehr auseinander und
vor welcher situation stehen wir jetzt
über ein jahrzehnt in der mache im juli
2015 wird das atom abkommen mit dem iran
unterzeichnet deutschland ist neben den
atommächten vertragspartner es bild als
sieg der diplomatie beschneidet das
iranische atomprogramm und verspricht
der iranischen bevölkerung ein ende der
wirtschaftssanktionen
[Musik]
heute haben die usa mit unseren partnern
etwas erreicht was jahrzehntelange
feindschaft nicht erreicht hat
inzwischen alles makulatur
letztes jahr kündigt trump einseitig den
atom-deal verhängt neue sanktionen
der iran setzt das abkommen
scheibchenweise aus fordert von den
europäern den usa ausstieg
wirtschaftlich zu kompensieren
mission impossible jetzt droht das
endgültige aus iran ungehemmt auf dem
weg zur atommacht derselbe iran der die
zerstörung israels zum staatsziel
erklärt der schutz israels ist aber
deutsche staatsräson wäre also iran der
die atombombe will nicht zwangsläufig
auch unser feind motive sind der reihe
nach liefert dieser angriff der usa
tatsächlich dem iran nicht gute
argumente diesen atom deal noch mehr zu
unterlaufen als er es bisher ohnehin
schon gemacht
eigentlich ja so war ja die erste
reaktion dann auch vom iran und ich
glaube beim nachdenken kann man auch zu
dem schluss momentan ist man auf der
moralischen sieger seite wenn man
großzügig vielleicht die wichtigsten
punkte des atoms weiter anerkennt und
auf diese weise vielleicht mit den
europäern tatsächlich ins gespräch kommt
und die amerikaner noch mehr isoliert
also da ist ne ich glaube sehr
ausgefeilte strategie ist im iran zu
erkennen momentan vom iranischen regime
und das dumme ist sowohl auf der seite
der usa ist keine strategie zu erkennen
ich habe es vorhin schon mal
angesprochen es gibt nicht den normalen
beratungs mechanismus isam us-regierung
wie es ihn früher gegeben hat es gibt
einen präsidenten der sagt was gemacht
wird und die anderen linken in der regel
dazu es gibt also keinen widerspruch und
es gibt kein vorausdenken und leider
schrecklicher weise herr gabriel geht
das aus meiner sicht für europa ganz
genauso
und da ist das jahr 2003 ein ganz
interessantes im jahr 2003 hat man in
der europäischen sicherheitsstrategie
hineingeschrieben
die einzelnen eu staaten sollten sich
gedanken
was für eine strategie sie entwickeln
wollen sicherheits mäßig nachdem elfter
september und dem irak krieg weil nur
wenn sich die einzelnen staaten darüber
klar werden was sie wollen strategisch
kann man auch zusammenkommen und eine
gemeinsame strategie entwickeln und da
ist leider muss man sagen in deutschland
nichts passiert im jahr 2008 hat eine
bundestagsfraktion von cdu und csu
einmal einen plan entworfen und ist
dafür geprügelt worden weil das wort
nationaler sicherheitsrat viel eine
sicherheitsarchitektur hier in
deutschland zu bauen bundespräsident
jetzige bundespräsident aber als
bundesaußenminister steinmeier hat
damals ganz klar dass sofort abgelehnt
für den als kunst braucht nur als
vizekanzler und andere in der es sehen
sie wie weit sei es weil es einen gibt
es in der heilig nicht vereint haben
jahre mitglied gewesen gaben live im
vergleich zu einer sicherheitsstrategie
der vereinigten staaten und den
nationalen sicherheitsrat aus einer hand
aber sie müssen jetzt die leute nicht
für dumm verkaufen das geht nach der
verfassung der bundesrepublik
deutschland natürlich nicht wie in den
usa nebenkriegsschauplätze das ist
einfach sich fragt was ich damit sagen
will nicht sich den leuten eine
nationale sicherheitsstrategie die mal
dargelegt hat was sind die interessen
und es gibt auch keine strukturen in
dieser regierung in dieser
bundesregierung die dann in der lage
wäre diese nationale
sicherheitsstrategie einerseits aus zu
führen andererseits auch mit den
europäischen partnern zu koordinieren
wir schauen uns jetzt die eu an die sie
gerne hier stärken wollen ich halte das
für absolut richtig aber wenn sich die
eu jetzt anschauen dann sind eigentlich
nur frankreich großbritannien und
deutschland diejenigen die ihre lage und
willens sind vielleicht diese politik im
nahen osten voranzutreiben während die
meisten anderen allen voran die
osteuropäer da nicht gut das ist ein
gegenbeispiel die ukraine der konflikt
in der ukraine der zu eskalieren drohte
ist durch das handeln der deutschen
kanzlerin und des französischen
präsidenten stellvertretend für europa
eingegangen
das ist keiner die leas ein kleines
gesetz und kassiert er eine europäische
strategie im nahen osten haben
stimmt aber so zu tun als ob sozusagen
europa deshalb nicht handlungsfähig ist
weil wir nicht 28 zusammenkriegen
ich wäre froh wenn deutschland
frankreich großbritannien als die
signatur staaten aus europa des atom
abkommen sind diese strategie wie sie
2003 begonnen wurde
wann hat er über ein leben haben werden
im irak das ist doch wie genau es ist
doch glücklicherweise mal so und das ist
doch auch eine ausnahme dass die
europäischen staaten wirklich ein
glücksfall im irak eigentlich gemeinsame
interessen haben
das ist in anderen kriegsgebieten nicht
so das ist zum beispiel in libyen nicht
so in syrien vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr aber auch nicht so richtig aber im
irak hat man das da kann man sagen gut
wir haben vielleicht ein bisschen
weniger interessen aber es ist wohl
unsere sicherheit auch relevant und wir
sollten wenn wir darum über eine rolle
für die europäische union oder die
europäischen staaten sprechen nicht
vergessen dass man das ganze nicht nur
durch das prisma usa iran sehen darf das
ist auch wichtig dass es eine abteilung
aber wir müssen eben auch schauen dass
wir die länder insbesondere den irak
stabilisieren denn wenn wir den ich kann
mit diesen jahres habe die
ausbildungsprogramme für soldaten meist
völlig übrigens auch politisches signal
ist weil dieses land ist es ist so eine
defizitäre demokratie den menschen die
dort demonstrieren demonstrieren nicht
nur gegen iran sondern auch gegen
ereignis systeme die politische klasse
aber es ist eine demokratie und ich kann
ihnen sagen ich bin ziemlich oft im irak
die menschen haben zwar die nase voll
von ihrem politischen system
aber wenn sie nach syrien schauen oder
in die andere richtung
dann würden sie ihr politisches system
das ihnen auch die amerikaner beschert
haben bei all diesen furchtbaren krieg
der danach gefolgt ist bevorzugen
und das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt den
wir nicht einfach aufgeben können und
sagen kann ja das sind das starten in
der nahen osten die bekriegen sicher
seid seid ja und im grunde auch das
schicksal der airlines forces also all
der länder die im irak jetzt engagiert
sind davon ab wie sich die us-amerikaner
verhalten ob die im land bleiben weil da
werden wir nicht bleiben können wenn die
amerikaner raus gehen das ist eigentlich
dafür zuständig sind auch gerade was den
luftraum angeht und die sicherheit aber
um es auch nochmal zu konkretisieren
gerade was den einsatz der bundeswehr
angeht das interessante und spannende
ist ja wirklich dass die deutschen
keinen nationalen interessen dort haben
und das macht sie so beliebt das macht
sie quasi
moderatorin zu mediatoren in ihrer die
vermitteln dort auch und dieser abzug
bedeutet vor einem hoffnungslosigkeit
also insofern glaube ich ist es ganz
wichtig auch unter dem hinter vor dem
hintergrund dass all die konflikte die
sich dort auch ja entwickeln
internationalisiert wurden sind und dass
wir auch nicht nur mehr unmittelbar
sondern mittelbar davon betroffen sind
wir merken das an dem städtischen
einfluss an den sunnitischen an seinem
radikalen sunnitischen weiß dass das so
zu sagen etwas ist was ja nicht halt
macht vor den toren europas und auch was
sozusagen das eigene sicherheits konzept
angeht sind wir gefragt mehr denn je
diese räume endlich zu besetzen damit
wir sie nicht den falschen überlassen
und das gilt für deutschland das gilt
europaweit und selbstverständlich auch
weltweit und ganz konkret für diese
krisenherde
ich verwehre mich dagegen so zu tun als
wenn das alles so zu sagen er genau wie
sie gesagt haben als wenn da alles
vorbei wäre ich würde den irak immer
noch sehr sehr spannend
wir haben bei möglichkeiten von
wiederaufbau von stabilisierung und wenn
wir sozusagen auch migration steuern
wollen in anführungsstrichen dann müssen
wir dafür sorgen dass diese region
sicher bleiben so und dann sind wir
jetzt trotzdem normal und hätten sich
nicht über frau becker ist jetzt an und
zwar möchte ich zurückkehren zu der
frage des atomdeals ist dieses also ist
die region mit dem atomdeal sicherer
geworden oder unsicherer geworden und
welche chancen gibt es jetzt überhaupt
noch nachdem die amerikaner raus sind
iran ist eigentlich überall gestärkt es
ist mit allen milizen mit allen
schiitischen kämpfer us-dollar hamas
also von libyen über irak über den
logisch also immer auch in jemen präsent
und hat tatsächlich geschafft sich in
dieser zeit stärker zu machen
wie groß ist die angst israels das ist
tatsächlich unter diesem erstarrten iran
zu leiten hat es ist ja unsere stadt
also die darüber haben wir haben noch
gar nicht gesprochen dass die sorge in
israel ist natürlich sehr groß
der iran unterstützt terroristische
gruppen die israel permanent angreifen
im prinzip auch in diesem im letzten
jahr
und genau nach die europäer angreift und
die der deal hat wie ich das vorher
schon gestellt aber aus meiner sicht die
region nicht stabiler gemacht sondern
unsicherer gemacht sieht man habe ich
eben haben wir eben schon darüber
gesprochen und zusätzlich würde ich
sagen und da hat natürlich auch israel
sorge ist der atom deal mit dem iran
kein sicherer schutz vor der entwicklung
der atombombe zumindest nicht
mittelfristig weil er im prinzip die
struktur des iranischen atomprogramms
intakt lässt weil er nicht genügende
inspektionen zulässt dann zum beispiel
in militärischen einrichtungen
da können nicht einfach zur inspektionen
stattfinden und was da genau passiert
wissen wir gar nicht es gibt aussagen
von der iranischen atombehörde die sagen
wir haben bestimmte anforderungen aus
denen die überhaupt nicht umgesetzt wie
zum beispiel die zerstörung des
plutonium reaktors in arag und das ist
sozusagen da hat habe ich auch gar keine
reaktion gesehen aus der eu oder den usa
das sind alles punkte die kann sein also
ebenfalls keine entscheidenden keine
schritte sozusagen die
eingeleitet wurden um wirklich diese
mechanismen eine institution zu stellen
die internationale atombehörde die
erklärt hat der iran hält alle auflagen
ein was sie jetzt sagen ist exakt die
argumentation natürlich wie wir von
anfang an hatten dass israelis und die
sozusagen teile der amerikaner gegen das
atomprogramm
ich finde nur ich hab das jetzt schon
allerdings auch von der
atomenergie-behörde dass sie diese für
diese selbst aussagen der iraner ernst
nehmen und sich da irgendwie festhalten
sie haben erklärt sind ja noch
aufgefordert worden noch mal hin zu
gehen ich finde das macht doch keinen
sinn jetzt eine schlacht noch mal
zuschlagen aber die sorge nicht sorgen
vor dem atom gekommen sondern von einem
abzug der amerikaner
ja das ist doch die größte sorge dass
die am dass die amerikaner jetzt
sozusagen ging direkt den iranern in die
hände spielen indem sie die region
verlassen und niemand da ist der das
ersetzen kann und dass die strategie
europas wir sind nicht gut genug
einverstanden wir sind nicht die starke
die strategie europas war die gleiche
wie die unter obama zu sagen weil die
irgendwann gehen müssen wir vertragliche
grundlagen schaffen bei denen wir über
eine lange strecke zu bringen
ich kann mein kleiner nur über das die
amerikaner da bleiben mit handeln den
iranern trauen sie waren häufig genug zu
gast ich habe sie das gefühl gehabt dass
sie da auf faire und auch ich kann ihr
das erste erlebnis meines besuches also
in israel kritisiert wurde dass ich in
den iran fahrer bin ich im iran von
einer zeitung der revolutionsgarden
empfangen wurden
auf dem titelblatt mein gesicht in der
mitte einer zielscheibe mit der
überschrift schmeißt diesen juden freund
wieder aus dem land also sie haben
beides dort sie haben leute mit denen
sie reden können und die wissen dass der
iran keine zukunft hat wenn er so weiter
macht und sie haben absolute hardliner
ein und was jetzt was jetzt was
was jetzt passiert ist die israelis
waren sich immer einig dass man gegen
den iran keinen krieg anfangen soll die
militärs haben in israel dagegen getan
was jetzt diskutiert was im iran
passiert ist dass diejenigen die immer
gegen den atom-deal warnen weil sie
gesagt haben mit dem satan im westen
macht keine verträge das bringt nichts
die fühlen sich jetzt gestärkt und sagen
den anderen die verhandelt haben da wo
ich immer gesagt was das sein und das
ganze hat uns eine fernwirkung ein paar
tausend kilometer weiter weg da sitzt
jemand der land gerade folgendes wenn du
so blöd bist mit europa verträge über
den verzicht auf atomwaffen zu machen
dann bist du am ende zielscheibe der
amerikaner
wenn du klug genug bist dir die
atombombe vorher zu besorgen
dann kommt der amerikanische und rede
über nordkorea oder auch dann wird dann
wird dann wird eine amerikanische
präsident kommen und sagen ich verfalle
mit der in liebe das ist die konsequenz
ein paar tausend kilometer weiter
nordkorea
deswegen glaube ich es macht keinen sinn
jetzt noch mal den versuch zu
unternehmen
über die frage zu reden was war jetzt
beim abkommen gut und weniger gut zu
wissen jetzt über die frage sprechen wie
füllen wir das drohende makellosen lud
ganze welt gefährlich
israel das surren der hand was so wie
ich die reaktion der israelis gerade
lesegut das land ist im dauerwahlkampf
gerade das neutralisiert natürlich auch
viel da ist man außenpolitisch dann
vielleicht nicht so viel unterwegs und
kommuniziert nicht so viel aber was
macht er dann ja oder wahrscheinlich der
einzige politiker ist im nahen osten war
dort der herren rooney an erfahrung das
wasser reichen können ja also der ist
mir somit einer der dienstältesten jetzt
da im nahen osten das war lange zeit
nicht so und absolut abgekocht und hat
ahnung von sicherheit von
nachrichtendienstlichen themen aber vor
allem natürlich von politik und hat
politischen instinkt der sagt in seinem
kabinett das war ein amerikanischer
aktion haben wir nichts mehr zu tun
nachdem die amerikaner haben verlauten
lassen er die israelis seien darüber
informiert gewesen
natürlich die methode die könnte
wahrscheinlich hinter jauch zu sagen das
ist zwar nicht genau die methode wie sie
die israelis angewandt haben aber es ist
durchaus verwandt aber die israelis
machen sich große sorgen klappt und eine
andere sache worüber die sich auch
entschuldigung bin ich dass anlagen
haben die israelis machen sich bestimmt
große sorgen wenn sie sich anschauen wie
eigentlich dieser angriff auf die us
basis al-assad verlaufen ist denn ich
bin kein militärexperte aber ich wundere
mich über eine sache die rhader schießen
diese raketen los als symbolische geste
sie wollen niemanden treffen indem man
keine haben eine luftwaffenbasis die
offensichtlich nicht die offensichtlich
nicht in der lage ist oder sie sagen
zumindest die sie haben nicht
absichtlich gezielt auf menschen und sie
wollen den tod von sie haben den kauf zu
nehmen aber sie haben
sie haben nicht habe ich darauf gezielt
aber diese luftwaffenbasis kann hat
offensichtlich nicht das material um
sich obwohl die amerikaner über
eigentlich immer ziemlich
gute technologie verfügung um raketen
abzufangen sich zu schützen was ist denn
das von der nachricht bedeutet das dass
die raketen noch nicht verkabelt wurden
die patriots die man sicherheit liefern
lassen oder was was ist das eigentlich
von der nachricht und ich und wo die
arabien nach dem natürlichen und da
sehen wir da sehen wir eine sache
man kann über das iranische regime
denken was man will es geht in so einer
auseinandersetzung ja nicht nur darum
wer ist militärisch stärker da sind die
amerikaner nummer eins weltweit sondern
wer ist leidensfähige wer ist denn
bereit ein bisschen mehr in kauf zu
nehmen der kann einstellung sein und da
wissen alle und das wissen auch die
israelis das ist ja mal dass das dass
das iranische recht dass ein anderer
mehr frauen mittlerweile den amerikanern
das ist meine lesart der der der
verhältnisse der letzten tage
ich glaube die ist ja ich glaube erst
mal frau becker hat in einem punkt
wesentlich recht die iraner haben
getrickst und getäuscht bis zum abwinken
oder auch mit dem atom deal auch noch
versucht weiter zu tricksen das hat
einen bericht der iaa ergeben
und auf dieser grundlage wurde ja dann
diskutiert und wie ich finde auch völlig
zu recht wie kann man das kontroll
regime zu ist so verschärfen dass es
funktionieren kann
das heißt also nicht dass der ganze deal
überflüssig ist man muss das
kontrollrecht aber sie haben es erst mal
erfolgreich unterland ist bevor das das
ganze netz muss dass man zurück das
langsamste unten
sie haben es unterlaufen das lässt sich
nachweisen so jetzt kommt aber der punkt
dann steigt aber doppeltop aus dem atom
biel
damit ist jede möglichkeit zur
verschärfung des kontrollen regimes
obsolet die ganze nicht welche chance
hat dann europa noch ich glaube dass
noch nicht diese atomdeal gestorben ist
auch wenn donald trump das sagt also die
frage ist können die europäer selber ich
weiß nicht wo sie die stärke finden
hoffentlich finden sie die und wenn es
nur drei sind die briten die deutschen
und die franzosen es schaffen mit dem
iran vielleicht auch noch mit anderen zu
schauen ob man diesen atomdeal in dieser
sache nachschärfen kann und die israelis
haben das gefühl das ist ja gar
überschritten hat die amerikaner
deutschland möchte mit dieser region
möglich zu drehen
und nochmal die frage nach israel ja das
ist für israel dramatisch wenn die
amerikaner glauben dass sie mit dieser
region in dieser region nicht bereit
sind menschenleben aufs spiel zu setzen
nämlich dass ihre eigenen soldaten
die wirklich werden wird den europäern
trauen dass wir die sicherheit
garantieren und wo ist unsere stadt
lieben gründe gelassen was was die
geschichte hat genug gründe geliefert
was passiert jetzt das ist nur eine
vermutung jetzt gibt es einen der sagt
ich habe auch super flugabwehrsysteme ja
da hat er schon angebot und ja er
verkauft sie an die türkei und den iran
er hat sie jetzt auch ihre waren
angeboten als nächstes wird er sie im
irak ruwer er wird jeden fragen und ich
glaube dass die gefahr wenn die
amerikaner gehen nicht nur ist dass wir
insgesamt an einfluss verlieren sondern
auch israel bemüht sich um gute
beziehungen zu russland
das heißt wir erleben das ist finde ich
sollte uns europäer mal gedanken machen
wir erleben einen vormarsch sozusagen an
ich glaube würde mir protokollchef vor
lachen nicht im schlaf wie einfach es
ihnen gelingt in der region eine
stellung einzunehmen die er nie hatte
und ich finde das noch mal ein beweis
dafür dass öffentlich nach november 2020
wieder zu einer strategischen
außenpolitik der usa zurück kommen und
deshalb hoffentlich auch so ein europa
deshalb wundert man sich dann erst recht
dass die bundeskanzlerin mit dem
außenminister als erstes jetzt nach
moskau fliegt wenn ich das richtig weiß
dann ist diese reise ja geplant gewesen
um über die ukraine zu reden richtig ist
ich hoffe sehr dass aber die europäer
wir haben vorhin geredet frankreich
großbritannien deutschland parallel dazu
selbst überlegt welche angebote sie in
der region machen kann und mit den
amerikanern verabredungen trifft das sie
dulden was die europäer machen mein
gefühl ist dass der tramp gar nicht so
unglücklich darüber sein würde wenn die
europäer einen eigenen verhandlungsweg
aufmachen
die amerikaner müssen den mit decken und
becken das müssen sie nicht öffentlich
machen aber dann glaube ich kann man in
der region und ist meine chance und frau
becker schüttel den ganzen die ganze
zeit den kopf und sagen das wird den
frieden nicht bringen genau das wird den
frieden nicht bringen das denke ich
wir letztendlich auch alle was genau das
sage ich jetzt also sie hatten ja gesagt
der im iran hat im prinzip auch die
opposition verloren das regime hat
gewonnen dass wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe und ich würde sagen das
hat aber jetzt gar nichts mit dem
militärschlag zu tun sondern die
proteste die größten proteste die es im
iran seit jahrzehnten gab im november
sind brutal niedergeschlagen worden
1500 menschen sind getötet worden 7000
sitzen im gefängnis und mit großer
gefahr dass diese gefoltert oder auch
getötet werden und die die bevölkerung
hat aber gezeigt dass sie dieses regime
nicht mehr wollen also alle zehn jahre
werden da sozusagen wird die jugend da
im prinzip liquidiert und ich denke dass
wir ganz dringend
wir müssen uns die frage stellen wie
lange wollen wir an der seite dieses
brutalen regime stehen wie lange wollen
wir das noch stabilisieren was
eigentlich nicht zu stabilisieren
die opposition die demokratische
opposition die müssen wir viel stärker
in den blick nehmen und totales
sozusagen die zukunft des nahen ostens
das sind die menschen die wir
unterstützen müssen und wir müssen uns
irgendwann verabschieden davon dieses
antisemitische terrorregime so muss man
das bezeichnen weiter zu unterstützen
auch wenn wir wollten bis dahin jede
zuschauer und sofort zu markus lanz
übergebe ich muss es sagen und ich
möchte als auch sagen diese diskussion
und den gästen hier heute abend sehr
herzlich danken
markus lanz hat unter anderem bodo
ramelow zu gast und wir sehen uns wenn
sie mögen nächsten donnerstag um 22.15
wieder ganz herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]